let's bring in our panel thanks hillary
josh crash our axios senior political
correspondent syndicated radio host hugh
hewitt molly hemingway editor-in-chief
of the federalist josh i don't think
i've seen a uh
endorsement that just says eric yeah
well you can hear a lot of republicans
breathing a sigh of relief in missouri
because
there was a fear that trump would
endorse eric greitens
disgraced former governor credibly
accused by his ex-wife of domestic abuse
that would not have been a good look for
the party it would have it would have
divided the party and given a chance for
the former governor to win now it looks
like the attorney general eric schmidt
is the clear favorite trump decided not
to ultimately get involved in that race
but molly if either eric wins does
the former president get the w that's
really the question yeah this this
primary was such a mess it was so
fractious and has so many personal
issues in play i think he probably
played it about right by essentially
staying out of it by just waiting to the
last minute to give his blessing to both
candidates more interesting to see how
his endorsements in arizona with blake
masters and other key races will play
out to see the to see the effect of a
trump endorsement yeah i need to check
if vicki hartzler's middle name is eric
that's the real question hugh um listen
tomorrow's a big day for primaries
around the country
uh it will certainly tell us a lot more
about president trump's poll there is a
third eric by the way uh our friend
henry gomez in ohio went and found an
eric mcelroy on the ballot so we're not
sure he's out of it but what josh said
is true eric greitens will lose that
he's radioactive credibly accused of
rapes uh persuasively accused of
domestic violence against his wife and
child he's plummeted in the polls eric
schmitz and his successful ag so the
former president played that down the
middle he's strong with blake masters
who's ahead the michigan governor's race
he has
gone late for
uh not kevin rinke who i thought he was
going to go for so he often throws a
curveball for people but i think at the
end of the day it'll turn out to be
something people still covet on the
republican side that trump endorsement
yeah that's true we'll take a look at it
tomorrow all right panel stand by if you
would hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now